SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
THERE ALSO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
LASER [inaudible]
GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HUESO --
TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROCK [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
WHY COUNTY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR GAS
BEYOND THE REALM OUR GUEST IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE AND WILL
BE LEADING PRAYER THIS MORNING
BY OUR JOPLIN.
SYSTEM CHAU BORMAN AFTER WHICH
WERE ACTUALLY TO REMAIN STANDING
AND WE'RE GONNA BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR
CHIANG.
LET US BE CENTERED IN GOD'S
PRESENCE.
THIS PRAYER POEMAS FROM PRAYERS
FOR A THOUSAND YEARS BY J.
MCDANIEL.
IN THIS CENTURY ENGINE IN THE
CENTURY.
OUR DEEPEST HOPE OUR MOST TENDER
PRAYER.
IS LESS WE MAY LEARN TO LISTEN.
MAY WE LISTEN TO ONE ANOTHER AN
OPENNESS AND MERCY.
MAY WE LISTEN TO PLANTS AND
ANIMALS IN WONDER AND RESPECT.
MAY WE LISTEN TO OUR HEARTS.
AND LOVE AND FORGIVENESS.
MAY WE LISTEN TO GOD'S IN
QUIETNESS AND ALL.
AND IN THIS LISTENING WHICH IS
BOUNDLESS AND ITS BEAUTY.
MAY WE FIND THE WISDOM TO
COOPERATES WITH THE HEALING
SPIRIT.
A DIVINE SPIRIT.
WHO BECKONS US INTO PEAS AND
COMMUNITY AND CREATIVITY?
WE DO NOT ASK FOR A PERFECT
WORLD.
BUT WE DO ASK FOR A BETTER WORLD.
WE ASK FOR DEEP LISTENING.
A MAN [inaudible]
READY BEGIN.
RIGHT TO SURVIVE.
YEAH.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER OUR
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY TELLS
US FOR ALL.
RIGHT NOW PREVENTION.
FOR PROVISIONS OF THE FLOOR.
SENATOR JONES ARE YOU READY.
YES SERVICE PRESIDENT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
COLLEAGUES AND I GUESS.
HI I HAVE ONE OF THE GREATEST
HONORS OF MY SERVICE HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE TODAY.
MR PRESENT WOULD YOU MIND
CALLING THE HOUSE TO ORDER
PLEASE FOR ME I'D APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LADIES AND
JOHN IF I COULD HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION I'D REALLY APPRECIATE
IT -- WERE
HONORED HERE --
THIS MORNING.
AS MANY OF YOU MAY KNOW --
MY GRANDFATHER FLEW B. TWENTY
FOURS IN WORLD WAR.
TWO AND SURVIVED EIGHTEEN MONTHS
IN A JET W. CAMP WELL.
THERE ARE TOO MANY OF THOSE
HEROES LEFT.
WITH US BUT TODAY.
WE ARE BLESSED TO BE JOINED
TODAY FROM A RESIDENT OF FAIR
OAKS CALIFORNIA.
FIRST LIEUTENANT RYAN MICHAEL
O'BRIEN [inaudible]
HE IS.
RECENTLY RECEIVED THE CHEVALIER
OF THE FRENCH LEGION OF HONOR.
ON JULY TENTH FROM THE FRENCH
CONSULATE IN SAN FRANCISCO.
EARLIER THIS WEEK MARCH
NINETEENTH WAS HIS NINETY
SEVENTH BIRTHDAY.
HE WAS BORN IN NINETEEN TWENTY
TWO IN LOS ANGELES.
IN NINETEEN FORTY ONE HE I
GRADUATED FROM MOUNT CARMEL HIGH
SCHOOL IN LA.
AND BECAME A JOURNEYMAN
BRICKLAYER.
HE'S A MEMBER OF THE VFW POST
SIXTY ONE FIFTY EIGHT THE
AMERICAN LEGION POST THREE
EIGHTY THREE A MEMBER OF THE
KNIGHTS OF COLUMBUS.
AND A RECOGNIZED KEYNOTE SPEAKER
AT VETERANS EVENTS.
IN NINETEEN FORTY THREE HE
JOINED THE U. S. ARMY AIR CORPS.
AND BECAME A B. TWENTY FOUR
FLIGHT NAVIGATOR.
HIS A SERVICE IN --
TO OUR COUNTRY TOOK HIM FROM
CALIFORNIA. TO TEXAS TO FLORIDA
AND THEN EVENTUALLY. TO THIS
SERRA NOLA ITALY.
HE FLEW HIS --
FIRST BE TWENTY FOUR FOR MARCH
FIELD IN RIVERSIDE TO SERRANO
ITALY.
ON A MIDNIGHT FLIGHT OVER THE
NORTH ATLANTIC WITHOUT RADIO.
AND ONLY USING CELESTIAL
NAVIGATION.
HE FLEW THIRTY FOUR MORE
MISSIONS. ONE OF THOSE MISSIONS
THE THE PLANE WAS UNABLE TO TAKE
OFF AND WAS UNDER FIRE FROM THE
GERMAN --
GROUND FORCES AT THAT TIME IN
HIS AIRPLANE WAS ACTUALLY SAVED
BY OSCAR SCHINDLER WHO PROVIDED
THE GERMAN ARMY WITH --
DEAD SHELLS FOR THE SHELLS WHEN
THEY HIT THE AIRPLANES DIDN'T
EXPLODE.
AND ALSO OSCAR SCHINDLER IN IN
IN IN ADDITION TO SAVING MANY
PEOPLE FROM THE GAS CHAMBER ALSO
SAVED MANY AMERICAN OF PILOTS
AND CREWMEN --
FROM DEATH AS WELL HERE --
SERVED ALMOST OVER FORTY YEARS
IN THE IN CALIFORNIA WITH THE
MASONS CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA WHICH HE HELPED FOUND
IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY TWO LIEUTENANT
RYAN MICHAEL BRIAN HAS BEEN
RECOGNIZED WITH THE
DISTINGUISHED FLYING CROSS. FOR
AIR MEDALS.
ORDER OF THE PURPLE HEART.
EUROPEAN AFRICAN MIDDLE EASTERN
METAL. THREE BATTLE STARS.
AND HIS --
BOMB GROUP FOR A FOURTH OF BOB
GROUP WAS RECOGNIZED WITH THE
PRESIDENTIAL UNIT CITATION.
IN HIS SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY HE
HAS FLOWN OVER EUROPE TO PLACES
LIKE PLASTI.
VIENNA ALON AUGSBURG SARAJEVO
BLACK CALMER I IN INNSBRUCK.
LINDS MUNICH BUDAPEST ZAGREB
[inaudible]
BOLOGNA.
MINOR.
NEW STAD ANDROS.
LADIES AND JOHN IS A GREAT HONOR --
FOR ME TODAY TO RECOGNIZE AND
HONOR IN INTRODUCED TO YOU THE
TENET RYAN MICHAEL O'BRIEN
.
I THINK
[inaudible]
TO EARLIER
.
NOW SHE HAD WHICH SHE PER MIKE
AGAIN WELCOME ATTENDED O'BRIEN
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE
UNITED STATES SUCH GIVE A MAN
AGAIN THANK YOU.
THE PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR
SENATOR ALLEN ARE YOU READY YEAH
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO JUST
MARK TODAY TODAY'S A VERY VERY
SPECIAL DAY IN THE JEWISH
CALENDAR AND AS CHAIR THE
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS.
I WANT TO WE WERE EXPRESS MY
MADE MY CELEBRATION AND WISH
EVERYBODY A VERY VERY HAPPY POOR
AND CAN YOU WITH MEDICINE AROUND
JUST GIVE US A MINUTE TO GET
SICK.
TODAY IS POOR EMPORIUM IS THE
MOST JOYOUS DAY IN THE JEWISH
CALENDAR AND IT CELEBRATES THE
SAVING OF THE JEWISH PEOPLE FROM
A GENOCIDAL MANIAC --
BACK IN THE DAYS OF ANCIENT
PERSIA AND THE STORY IS TOLD IN
THE BOOK OF ESTHER IN THE BIBLE
IN FACT THIS MONTH AS WE KNOW IS --
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH AND WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT HOW WE'VE BEEN
CELEBRATING LOTS OF WONDERFUL.
FIGURES IN IN WOMEN'S HISTORY
THE JEWISH PEOPLE COURSE ARE SO
PROUD TO HAVE SO MANY.
STRONG WOMEN IN OUR HISTORY FROM
THE MATRIARCH SIERRA ALL THE WAY
THROUGH TO HANNAH BETH JACKSON
[inaudible]
AND AND THIS PARTICULAR HOLIDAY
CELEBRATES THE BRAVERY AND
COURAGE OF ASTOR.
AND HER ACT IN IN SAVING THE
JEWISH PEOPLE FROM --
FROM ANNIHILATION.
AND SO THIS IS A JOYOUS HOLIDAY
THAT WE CELEBRATE ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
I PEOPLE DRESS UP IN COSTUME AND
AND WE'RE ACTUALLY HAVING
CELEBRATION HERE IN THE CAPITAL
NEXT WEEK.
BUT ACROSS IT ON WEDNESDAY.
BUT I WANTED TO JUST TAKE A
MOMENT.
A CELEBRATION TODAY AND SHOW YOU
GUYS THESE LITTLE COOKIES THAT I
BROUGHT IN THESE ARE CALLED
HAMANN TASCHEN.
AND THEY REPRESENT THESE THE
TRIANGULAR HAT THAT WAS WORN BY
THE BAD GUY.
AND SO WE EAT THESE LITTLE
COOKIES ON THIS DAY AND WE FILL
THEM UP WITH POPPY SEED OR WITH
WITH APRICOT OR RASPBERRY AND SO
I KNOW WE'RE NOT ALLOWED TO EAT
ON THE FLOOR BUT I BROUGHT.
SOME SOME OF THESE --
WONDERFUL LITTLE COOKIES I TO
SHARE WITH YOU AFTER SESSION IF
YOU ARE SO INCLINED SO I JUST
WANT TO WISH EVERYONE.
A HUG THE MATH HAPPY HAPPY PORN.
ALSO THEIR PURPOSE IN FLOOR ANY
FURTHER PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
I JUST WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO WISH A HAPPY
BIRTHDAY TO SENATOR HER TITLE.
I MEAN I'M SORRY SENATOR RAJO
SENATOR RAZA WAS JUST CELEBRATED
HER.
BIRTHDAY YESTERDAY.
LET'S GIVE A ROUND OF WHAT'S HER
BIRTHDAY.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DOING READ.
REPORTS FROM COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR MARCH EIGHTEENTH
THROUGH THE TWENTY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK.
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
[inaudible]
WE RACE.
SECOND READING FILE SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIXTY SIX WITH A
MOMENT SENATE BILL THREE OR ONE
WITH THE MOMENTS SENATE BILL
FIVE SENATE BILL THIRTY FOUR
WITH THE MOMENTS.
SENATE BILL ONE TWENTY WITH
MINUTES AND SENATE BILL TWO OF
FIVE MINUTES [inaudible] SIX
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS.
ARE THERE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT
SENATOR WILL [inaudible]
I'D.
SEVEN THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
DOING A FINE JOB THIS MORNING.
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS OF FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF KEENLY BASSLER
AS A DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE.
MS BOXER HAS EXTENSIVE THE
BUDGET EXPERIENCE TO HER
PREVIOUS WORK AT THE LA --
THE SENATE BUDGET A FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION.
AND AS IN CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
MISS BASSER ALSO SERVE FOR TWO
YEARS AS CABINET SECRETARY FOR
GOVERNOR BROWN.
SHE WAS APPROVED BY UNANIMOUS
VOTE BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON
MARCH SIX AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CONSIDER DOZEN UNDER THE SIDE
[inaudible]
YES.
THIS PRESENT LAYS DOWN THE
SENATE I RISE IN SUPPORT OF KEY.
HER POSITION.
SHE HAILS FROM A RURAL COUNTY.
WENT TO CHICO STATE.
IT WAS QUITE A INTERESTING
COURSE THAT HER LIFE IS TAKEN.
FROM THE AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY
TO THE HIGHEST LEVELS IN STATE
GOVERNMENT.
AND OVER MY YEARS OF WORKING
WITH TV I'VE FOUND IT TO BE VERY
RESPONSIVE [inaudible]
THOROUGH [inaudible]
AN EXPERT.
HE'LL DO A FINE JOB AND IN FACT
ALREADY HAS THE DIRECTOR OF
FINANCE I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
IN ACQUIRING THIS APPOINTMENT.
YES THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT I'LL MAKE MY COMMENTS
BRIEF -- I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF MISS BASEL
ARE UP FOR VERY PERSONAL REASONS.
HI THERE IS BEEN VERY FEW
BESIDES MISS BASSER WHO
DELIVERED FOR THOSE WHO SURVIVED
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES.
SHE HAS BEEN AVAILABLE HE'S BEEN
INNOVATIVE IN HER APPROACH AND
SHE IS DELIVERED ON HER WORD TO
MAKE SURE THAT FIRE SURVIVORS
ARE KEPT WHOLE AFTER THESE
MASSIVE DISASTERS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A SUPPORT
BOAT HERE.
A AT THE PERFECT TIME IS PRESENT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE APPOINTMENT HERE AND SEEN
ON SENATOR WHAT WHAT TO LOOK
CLOSE.
WHICH IF THEY DON'T CLOSE FOR
DOUBLE TROY POINTS BUT BE HAPPY
TO DO THAT FOR YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE APPOINTMENT [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
BY BILL.
BY BURGESS.
BY BRADFORD HI HI CAMBIADO.
BY CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
BY THE RISE OF GALGIANI
[inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
BY HILL AYE HUESO.
BY HER TITLE [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
HI LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK.
I'M.
AYE NIELSEN.
BY PAN.
BY PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH BY RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I AM BURKE.
BY WHAT COUNTY.
BY WINNER.
BY WILK HI
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL OUT TO
MEMBERS DORADO [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
GROWTH RUBIO.
ICE THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
COMPLETE APPOINTMENTS CONFIRMED
AND NEXT WE HAVE SENATE THIRD
READING ITEMS. FOURTEEN SIXTEEN
TO SEVENTEEN CENTER CAPITAL ARE
ARE YOU READY AT THIS TIME
[inaudible]
I AM.
I AM FOURTEEN WAS SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
THE RESOLUTION TWENTY FIVE BY
SENATOR CAFIERO RELATIVE TO
WOMEN'S MILITARY HISTORY WEEK.
WHEN YOU REDUCE CENTER?
MISTER PRESIDENT AND SENATORS I
RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS TO PRESENT SR
TWENTY FIVE WHICH RECOGNIZES THE
WEEK OF MARCH EIGHTEENTH THROUGH
THE TWENTY SECOND AS WOMEN'S
MILITARY HISTORY WEEK IN
CALIFORNIA.
IT'S BEEN SIX YEARS SINCE THE
BAN WAS LIFTED ON WOMEN SERVING
IN COMBAT AND FOUR YEARS SINCE
THE UNITED STATES SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE.
ASHTON CARTER DIRECTED THE FULL
INTEGRATION OF WOMEN IN TO ALL
MILITARY BRANCHES.
IN REALITY HOWEVER WOMEN HAVE
SERVED IN EVERY MAJOR UNITED
STATES CONFLICT SINCE THE
AMERICAN REVOLUTIONARY WAR.
FROM EIGHTEEN WOUNDED SOLDIERS
SUPPLYING FOOD AND CLOTHING TO
THE OVER FOUR HUNDRED WOMEN WHO
DISGUISED THEMSELVES AS MEN. TO
FIGHT IN THE CIVIL WAR WOMEN
SIGNIFICANT X. SIGNIFICANT PART
OF OUR UNITED STATES MILITARY.
AND WOMEN'S IMPACT HAS ONLY
GROWN IN THE LAST CENTURY
ACCORDING TO THE DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT.
WOMEN CURRENTLY MAKE UP 20% OF
THE AIRFORCE 19% OF THE NAVY 15%
OF THE ARMY AND ALMOST 9% OF THE
MARINE CORPS.
WOMEN HAVE SERVED IN GATHERING
INTELLIGENCE AS COMBAT PILOTS
FIELD ARTILLERY OFFICERS
CHAPLAIN SPECIAL OPERATIONS
CIVIL AFFAIRS OFFICERS AND EVEN
EVEN AS MEMBERS OF THE ULTRA
SECRETIVE.
DELTA FORCE AND WOMEN HAVE
SERVED BRAVELY FEMALE SERVICE
MEMBERS HAVE EARNED MORE THAN
TEN THOUSAND COMBAT ACTION
BADGES AND BRONZE STARS AND AT
LEAST TWELVE BRONZE STARS WITH
VALOR.
WOMEN NOW MAKE UP APPROXIMATELY
10% OF THE CURRENT VETERAN
POPULATION THE FASTEST GROWING
DEMOGRAPHICS IT'S CLEAR THERE IS
A DESIRE AND A WILLINGNESS AMONG
WOMEN TO SIR.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN CELEBRATING
WOMEN'S MILITARY HISTORY WEEK
WHICH ENCOURAGES CALIFORNIANS TO
RECOGNIZE THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
WELL WOMEN TO OUR MILITARY AND
TO OUR FREEDOM.
AND HONOR THE SACRIFICES THAT
WOMEN HAVE MADE WHILE SERVING
OUR COUNTRY BOTH BEFORE AND
AFTER THE LIFTING OF THE BAN
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THE DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
IF THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
TO RISE AND SUPPORT AS A STATE
SENATOR REPRESENTING MARINE
CORPS BASE CAMP PENDLETON
LOCATED HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
CERTAINLY IN THE THIRTY SIX
SENATE DISTRICT.
I AM PLEASED TO BE A CO AUTHOR
OF THE RESOLUTION WOMEN HAVE
LONG SERVED OUR COUNTRY WITH THE
FIRST FEMALE MARINE CAPTAIN
LILLIAN DALY ASSIGNED TO CAMP
PENDLETON.
IN NINETEEN FORTY THREE NOW
THERE ARE OVER TWENTY SIX
HUNDRED WOMEN MARINES STATIONED
AT CAMP PENDLETON INCLUDING
LIEUTENANT COLONEL MICHELLE
MCANDREW.
WHO LAST YEAR BECAME THE FIRST
WOMAN TO COMMAND A COMBAT UNIT
AT THE BASE OUR WOMEN WARRIORS
TO SERVE OUR COUNTRY DESERVE THE
UTMOST RESPECT AND HONOR?
BY IT TO ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR OCULATA.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I TO
RISE IN SUPPORT.
ON A PERSONAL NOTE. ONE OF MY
SONS AND ARMY RANGER CAPTAIN
RIGHT NOW SPECIAL FORCES AND HE
WAS SO PROUD TO HEAR.
THAT THESE THREE WOMEN BECAME
ARMY RANGERS AND I ASKED HIM
WHAT HE FELT ABOUT THAT THESE
THE DAD I THINK THAT'S THE
GREATEST THING THAT'S EVER
HAPPENED UNITED STATES MILITARY.
BECAUSE WOMEN ARE SERVING
PROUDLY RIGHT NOW AS I REMIND
YOU TIME AND TIME AGAIN THAT I
SHARE WITH THE EIGHTY SECOND
AIRBORNE WE HAVE WOMEN.
WHO ARE IN THE EIGHTY SECOND
AIRBORNE MY DAUGHTER IN LAW --
WHO GRADUATED FROM WEST POINT?
ALSO WHERE'S HE'S PAIRED COOPER
WINGS I PROUDLY WEAR.
SO I TELL YOU ALL THE PLEASE.
REACH OUT TO ALL THE WOMEN YOU
FIND WERE SERVING OUR MILITARY
ARE VETERANS AND UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY ARE EQUAL.
TO AND IN SOME CASES GREATER
THAN SOME OF THE MEN AND WOMEN
THAT THAT WERE SERVING IN THE
PAST TODAY'S WOMEN ARE THE BEST
OF THE BEST.
WHEN I WAS A PRESIDENTIAL
APPOINTEE WITH THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY? TO OF FLY ON DECK
THE USS NIMITZ AND I WAS THERE.
AND IT WAS THAT A JET PLANE AND
IT WAS -- AN
ENGINE ON THE GROUP ON THE FLOOR
THERE AND I ASKED --
WHO'S IN CHARGE IN A WOMAN STOOD
UP A VERY PROUDLY SAID SIR I AM
IN CHARGE OF THIS PLANE IT IS MY
PLANE AND IS MY CREW.
IT WILL FLY TOMORROW AND SURE
ENOUGH THE NEXT MORNING ON DECK
THAT PLANE FLEW OVER --
AS WENT AROUND AND I LOOKED OVER
MY PLANE SO.
YES INDEED THE WOMEN CAN DO IT
AND I'M SO PROUD TO SHARE THAT
AND I RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
A BIT ON THE SIDE ON SCENE ON
CENTRE COBBLER WHICH OUGHT TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
TO MY FELLOW SITE SENATORS FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNITED UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USE ANY
IN ADAMS ROLL CALL.
SEE NINE THIRTY SIX ZERO MOTION
PASSES.
NEXT UP ITEM.
SIXTEEN CENTER I'M BURKE.
BUT THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES I'M THE SECRETARY
PLEASE READ OFTEN OCCUR
RESOLUTION SEVEN BY SENATOR
UMBERG RELATIVE TO BLACK APRIL
MORE A MONTH --
CENTER ON BURKE THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I HAVE THE
DISTINCT HONOR OF REPRESENTING
THE LARGEST VIETNAMESE COMMUNITY.
OUTSIDE OF VIETNAM.
TODAY I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
AND CONTINUE THE ANNUAL
TRADITION OF RECOGNIZING APRIL
IS BLACK APRIL MEMORIAL MONTH OF
MANY OF US REMEMBER.
APRIL OF NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
PARTICULARLY APRIL THIRTIETH
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE AS WE
WATCHED ON TELEVISION AS
VIETNAMESE WERE AIRLIFTED OFF
THE ROOF OF THE US EMBASSY IN
SAIGON.
OF THE VIETNAM WAR WAS A TRAGEDY --
FOR VIETNAM ALSO A TRAGEDY HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES --
AND WE RECALL THAT FIFTY EIGHT
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
AMERICANS MADE THE ULTIMATE
SACRIFICE AND MANY MANY MANY
THOUSANDS MORE BEAR THE SCARS OF
OF THAT CONFLICT --
THE VIETNAMESE PEOPLE INDOOR
TREMENDOUS SUFFERING --
AND THEY CONTINUE TO INDOOR
SUFFERING EVEN TILL TODAY --
THE THE UNITED STATES AND
PARTICULARLY OUR IT WAS BLESSED
BY THE GREAT NUMBER OF
VIETNAMESE REFUGEES WHO
IMMIGRATED TO THE UNITED STATES
THAT HAVE MADE OUR COMMUNITY IS
ALL THE MORE RICHER IN FACT NOW.
THEY'RE ALMOST A HALF A MILLION
VIETNAMESE AMERICANS LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA.
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
REMEMBER AND RECOGNIZE THE
SACRIFICES TRAGEDY WE RECOGNIZE
THE VIETNAMESE AMERICANS ARE
HERE AND THE VIETNAMESE WHO ARE
STILL FIGHTING FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
FOR DEMOCRACY.
AND FOR EQUALITY IN VIETNAM AND
SO I'D ASK YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
RESOLUTION.
AT ASKED THAT WE STEP BACK AND
REMEMBER DURING THE MONTH OF
APRIL THOSE SACRIFICES AND
PARTICULARLY ON APRIL THIRTIETH.
I ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SCENE NINE SOONER ON BURKE
TAUGHT CLOSE.
JUST ASK FOR YOUR VOTE THANK
VERY MUCH.
MEMBERS THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THE SITE.
SCENE NINE THE ITEM PASSES.
THIRTY SIX ZERO NEXT UP SOONER
CHIANG ITEM.
SEVENTEEN ARE YOU READY.
MS SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TWENTY TWO
BY SENATOR CHIANG RELATIVE TO
ARAB AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH.
CENTER CHIANG.
GOOD MORNING MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES.
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT STR
TWENTY TWO WHICH RECOGNIZES
APRIL AS ARAB AMERICAN HERITAGE
MONTH.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO THE
LARGEST ARAB AMERICAN POPULATION
IN THE COUNTRY.
THE CONTRIBUTIONS MADE BY ARAB
AMERICANS BAND DIVERSE SECTORS.
FROM ACADEMIA BUSINESS
GOVERNMENT TECHNOLOGY TO POP
CULTURE.
WITH NOTABLES SUCH AS US
SECRETARY OF TRANSPORTATION RAY
LAHOOD.
CONGRESSMAN DARRELL ISA PAULA
ABDUL SAMA HAYEK SECURA PAUL ON
GOOD TO NAME A FEW.
NOT TO MENTION AMAZING EVER
AMERICAN INNOVATIONS WHICH
INCLUDE THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
ARTIFICIAL HEART BY DR MICHAEL
DEBAKEY.
AND THE INVENTION OF THE ICE
CREAM ERNEST HEMINGWAY. FOR WELL
OVER A CENTURY THE ARAB AMERICAN
COMMUNITY HAS ENRICHED OUR
CULTURE AND DEMOCRACY WITH
RESILIENT.
FAMILY VALUES.
STRONG WORK ETHIC AND A
DIVERSITY IN FAITH.
THE AMERICAN EXPRESS FOR EVER
ARAB AMERICANS THOUGH.
HAS NOT BEEN WITHOUT ITS
CHALLENGES AS THEY HAVE BEEN
DEFACED BY MISUNDERSTANDING.
AND BIGOTRY.
THIS IS WHY IT IS SO IMPORTANT
FOR US TO STAND COLLECTIVELY.
AS A STATE AND COUNTRY AND
CONDEMN THE KIND OF HATE THAT
CHRIST HURST RECENTLY INDOOR.
THAT KIND OF HATE HAS NO PLACE
IN SOCIETY.
PERIOD.
THE VICTIMS WERE DIVERSE THEY
WERE VERY PERCENT.
OF SOUTH ASIAN DESCENT
[inaudible]
PACIFIC ISLANDERS.
THEY SPEND MANY NATIONALITIES
AND CULTURES.
WHEN WE SEE CIVIL RIGHTS ABUSES?
HARMFUL STEREO TYPING HARASSMENT.
AND BULLYING HERE AT HOME IN ANY
FORM.
WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO STAND
TOGETHER.
AND REJECTED.
MY DISTRICT IS THE PROUD HOME OF
BROKER ST IN ANAHEIM MORE AS
IT'S REFERRED TO LOCALLY.
LITTLE ARABIA.
THIS CULTURAL FOCAL POINT
HIGHLIGHTS THE VIBRANCY OF THIS
COMMUNITY.
WHICH IS WHY THIS MAKES THIS
RESOLUTION PARTICULARLY SPECIAL
TO ME AND IS AN EXAMPLE OF HOW
WE CAN EMBRACE DIVERSITY. TO
STRENGTHEN OUR GREAT STATE.
I'M HONORED TO COMMEND ARAB
AMERICANS WITH THE MY DISTRICT
IN CROSS CALIFORNIA WITH S. YOUR
TWENTY TWO AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THROUGH MUCH ON THIS ITEM YEAH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT I STAND IN SUPPORT OF
THIS C. R. --
TWENTY TWO AND THERE WAS A
PARTICULAR SECTION OF THE
RESOLUTION --
BUT I THOUGHT MOST RATHER LIT UP
MISSION TO READ.
OBJECTION THANK YOU WHERE AS
ARAB MIGRANTS TO UNITED STATES
BROUGHT THEIR BROUGHT WITH THEM
THEY'RE RESILIENT FAMILY VALUES.
STRONG WORK ETHIC DEDICATION TO
EDUCATION DIVERSITY IN FAITH
INCREASE THAT I'VE ADDED
STRENGTH TO OUR GREAT DEMOCRACY
I WOULD ARGUE THAT THAT VERY.
PARAGRAPH --
IS RELEVANT TO ALL MY GREAT
COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE COME TO OUR
COME OUR GREAT STATE IN OUR
COUNTRY AND AGAIN OF ADDED GREAT
VALUE IN STRENGTH TO OUR
DEMOCRACY SO I STAND IN SUPPORT
OF THIS RESOLUTION.
AND ALL MY GREAT PEOPLE'S.
I THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
CENTERS I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION Y. THANK MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM DIAMOND BAR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD --
CERTAINLY IT IS AMERICA ARAB
AMERICANS HAVE CONTRIBUTED
GREATLY TO OUR GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND I HOPE THAT OUR COUNTRY WILL
EMBRACE POLICIES TO ALLOW EVEN
MORE OF THEM. TO COME HERE TO
THIS COUNTRY WE HAVE GREAT
SUFFERING WE SEE AND PARKS.
LIKE SYRIA AND OTHER PLACES BUT
YET OUR NATIONAL POLICIES HAVE
NOT ALLOWED --
THESE FAMILIES. TO COME TO OUR
COUNTRY AND BENEFIT FROM BE ABLE
TO CONTRIBUTE TO OUR COUNTRY AND
TO TO GAIN FROM THAT SO I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE THIS RESOLUTION
COMING FORWARD WE HAVE A
FANTASTIC EVERY AMERICAN
COMMUNITY HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE OTHER ARABS WHO
ARE INTERESTED ALSO BECOMING
ARAB AMERICANS AND I HOPE WE
WILL COME AND WE WILL WELCOME
THEM AS WELL THANK YOU --
TONIGHT AT THANK YOU SENATE
ALLEN.
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE LIVES
OF JEWISH CAUCUS I WANTED. TO
WRITE A VERY VERY STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS RESOLUTION AND I ALSO
WANT TO TO I I'VE UP FIRST ALL
SAY THAT I'VE VERY MUCH ENJOYED
EATING A LITTLE ARABIA AND IN
THE SENATORS DISTRICT IN IN
ANAHEIM THE SOME INCREDIBLE
RESTAURANTS THERE AND IF YOU
HAVE HAD A CHANCE. TO GO I I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO GO AND GET A
LITTLE TASTE OF THE MIDDLE EAST
THERE -- BUT
I ALSO WANT TO STAND IN TERRIBLE
EVENTS IN NEW ZEALAND COULD USE
CAUCUS PUT OUT A STATEMENT OF
IMMEDIATELY AFTERWARDS
CONDEMNING THE VIOLENCE WAS SO.
CLEAR TO US THAT THE SAME FORCES
OF BIGOTRY AND HATRED THAT
IMPACTED OUR COMMUNITY ARE
IMPACTING OUR MUSLIM BROTHERS
AND SISTERS AND I WAS TRYING TO
SEND A VERY VERY STRONG
SOLIDARITY WITH THAT COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SEEN HERE NINE CENTER CHIANG
WHICH LIKE CLOSE FLORA THINK MY
A ONE FOR COLLEAGUES FOR THE
COMMENTS AND WITH THAT I'D.
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS IS ITEMS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION OF USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING HEARING ON ITEM --
AGE THIRTY SIX THE MEASURE
PASSES.
THIS POINT WE HAVE COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
IN EIGHT COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
CENTER PAN.
I THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
THE BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE ON
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES WILL
BE CONVENING AND ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE AT NINE FORTY FIVE AM%
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN SENATOR OFF.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
EDUCATION WILL BE CONVENING IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE AT
NINE FORTY FIVE THANK YOU SIR
MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AT MISTER
PRESIDENT TODAY BY THE WAY SIR --
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE
ON FISHERIES AND AQUACULTURE
WILL BE MEETING TODAY AT ONE
THIRTY IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE REALLY NOTED.
SENATOR MITCHELL.
ON OUR JOBS ARE CENTER WHAT
KASKI YES MISTER PRESIDENT --
SUB COMMITTEE TO WILL BE MEETING
AT NINE FORTY FIVE IN ROOM.
ONE ONE TWO THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU I MISSED PRESIDENT.
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE PUBLIC
SAFETY IN THE JUDICIARY WILL
MEET IN ROOM ONE THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN MINUTES AFTER A GERMAN.
THANK YOU ARE THERE SENATOR.
DORADO.
YES THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FOR ITS
STATE ADMINISTRATION AND GENERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL MEET IN TEN
MINUTES IN ROOM. TWENTY FORTY
TWO LEE NOTED ARE THERE ANY
OTHER COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENT.
SENIOR NINE WERE MOVING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS IS TO BE
THE TIME FOR JOURNEY MEMORIES.
ARE THERE ANY ADJOURNMENT MARIE.
CENTER GALGIANI.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
ETHAN MARS ETHAN WAS KILLED IN A
DRIVE BY SHOOTING IN OUT WATER
ON MARCH FIFTEENTH.
HE WAS A STANDOUT WRESTLER
GOLDEN VALLEY HIGH SCHOOL AND
WAS A QUALIFIER FOR C. I. F.
STATE WRESTLING FINALS IN
BAKERSFIELD.
ETHAN WAS A STUDENT AT MERCED
COLLEGE AND EARNED WRESTLING
SCHOLARSHIP TO WASH SEAT AT
BAPTIST COLLEGE IN ARKANSAS.
ETHAN WAS THE SON OF LONG TIME
MERCED COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
LARRY MORSE AND HIS WIFE CINDY
WHO IS ALSO AN ATTORNEY.
LARRY.
LARRY IS CURRENTLY LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
ETHAN IS ALSO SURVIVED BY TWO
BROTHERS DILLON AND RYAN AND HIS
TWO YEAR OLD DAUGHTER AVA HE
WILL BE MISSED BY ALL.
WHO KNEW HIM THANK YOU?
THANK YOU WILL STAND OUR
CONDOLENCES AND BRING THE NAME
FOR TO CAN BE PROPERLY MORE
ALLIES.
ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL A
GERMAN MEMORIES.
SCENE.
NINE IF THERE'S NO FURTHER
BUSINESS.
SENATOR ACTIONS THE DEFICITS
COLOR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
CONGRATULATIONS TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM GARDENA WONDERFUL JOB TODAY --
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU AT THE
DíAS -- I
AGAIN WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE SANTEE
FOR BRING AND LIEUTENANT O'BRIEN
TO THE FLOOR IT IS AN
INCREASINGLY RARE PRIVILEGE THAT
WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE.
SOMEONE WHO IS A HERO IN WHO
SERVED IN WORLD WAR.
TWO SO WE THANK YOU FOR THAT AND
ALSO TO OUR COLLEAGUE --
WHO ALSO RECOGNIZED WOMEN'S
MILITARY HISTORY WEEK AS PART OF
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH --
WE HAVE SO MUCH TO BE THANKFUL.
FOR AND WITH THAT I HOPE WE GO
HOME TO OUR COMMUNITIES AND HAVE
A WONDERFUL WEEKEND WITH OUR
FAMILIES AND OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND WE WILL RE ADJOURN ON
RECONVENE RECONVENE ON MARCH
TWENTY FIFTH AT TWO PM THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES.
THE GROUND PRO TEM THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE
THIRTY AT WHICH TIME ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE WILL
RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO PM THIS
CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS FOR TODAY